there's a side of China's history the
Communist Party doesn't want you to know
about in China they want to inform you
at the coming new socialist person this
is the purpose of the limitation
underneath the facade of kitc propaganda
lies a system of forced penal labor in
prison farms known as lagaa why by 1956
Mouse communist revolution was complete
to ensure total censorship of counter
revolutionaries Soviet state experts
were invited in to develop a gulag style
prison Network numbering over a thousand
the major job in the prison camp just a
life to find a food that's it at age 23
Harry Wu was sent to the prisons from
1960 to 1979 because his father was a
banker and therefore linked to the
capitalist class who now lives in
America and directs the lugar Research
Foundation and the leg our Museum in
nineteen years I never read never write
never do anything I just like that
animal when Mao died in 1979 political
prisoners from the legaly stin cluding
Wu in 2013 the Chinese government
officially abolished reeducation through
labor camps but rights group Amnesty
International warned that the move would
be an empty gesture if they'd simply
abolish one system of arbitrary
detention only to expand the use of
others we returned to China in 1991 with
60 minutes to document the former Lajoie
prisoners they went with me and they
went into the lembeh camps they met the
prisoners and they make a few since then
I always try to tell the people that how
many camps where's the location and how
many people are asked to me probably
1000 labor camps and probably more than
440 million people was in the prison a
site from forced labor penitentiary
officials run an underground organ
market off dead prisoners as
subject move still has difficulty
recollecting to the to the coming I went
to China to 94 I went to the hospital
doc the doctor say hey what do you want
even organ not you I say bye uncle
it's okay nobody thirty does it have
your daughter who's the donor so we
don't talk about it
we guarantee fresh good quality dad you
are right doesn't matter who is Donna
and then they say just at Estoril
prisoners in 2008 we open the legume use
IAM located in Washington DC to preserve
the memory of victims and to raise
awareness of the human rights abuse by
the Communist Party of China but I want
to very clearly too that this museum is
not really for America it's particularly
for China I wish one day we can remove
it back to China
one thing is very very simple
today in China almost no one believed
that communism is their future so that's
why in the recently two years I tell the
people
China's come to the final stage
color and how to change we do not know
you